Oi como você tá você tá bem Tem alguma
coisa para falar para você sobre a Anna
todos os mais ricos delas leva a crer
que ela tem síndrome de Down bem com
isso eu lembro exatamente dessa conversa
se diálogo aconteceu há pouco mais de
dez anos no dia dez de setembro de 2010
quando a minha filha Ana Carolina nasceu
e eu lembro exatamente da maneira que
uma pessoa me tratou da maneira como ela
proposta do jeito que ela me olhou do
tom da voz dela a falar comigo e da
preocupação em primeiro saber como que
eu tava antes de me dar essa notícia já
que ela sabia que eu tava saindo do
momento que já é frágil de Março e por
causa de tudo isso para mim isso foi o
acho que o diagnóstico mais humanizado
que eu recebi Né desde então ele
o Messi diagnóstico receber o meu marido
e mal sabia eu que ao longo de muito
tempo vários outros diagnósticos viriam
várias outras consultas médicas e
terapias especialistas de que o ambiente
da saúde e do sistema de saúde a fazer
parte da minha vida grande parte da
minha vida e nem sempre eu iria receber
esse mesmo tratamento esta essa mesma
preocupação em como eu estava como
indivíduo e como aquele impactaria minha
vida Eu me chamo Juliana tenho 36 anos e
sua mãe de três crianças maravilhosas
que me deixam louca me tirando do sério
muitas vezes mas que também enche de
orgulho traz muita alegria para minha
vida que eu não consigo imaginar sem
eles e e por um acaso ele também tem
deficiência de níveis diferentes de
suporte necessário e
Que lindo isso para mim a maternidade da
gente a importância da gente considerar
o indivíduo no tratamento é a mesma lei
comentário maternidade eu tenho três
filhos eu sou muito três da mesma
maneira só que eu preciso lidar com cada
um de maneira diferente né tem o Cauê
que tem 11 anos ele é daltônico aqui em
PVH Então eu preciso olhar para as
outras coisas dele né então ele tem uma
tendência a melancolia a ficar isolado
ser mais tímidos ela tem que ter certeza
que ele tomou medicamento dele ele tá
fazendo terapia que eu tô dando as
palavras de encorajamento precisa para
seguir o dia a dia dele com a Ana ela
tem uma necessidade o depende de mim
para te das diárias para se limitar a se
vestir para se locomover
e eu preciso estar tentando comunicações
não-verbais que ela mimi e eu preciso
também para tenta quando eu vou dar um
banho nela e saber se eu nosso algum
carocinho que pode ser uma manifestação
da doença que ela tem então é um osso
pra também um novo e tem 7 anos e também
tem pregai também tá no espectro eu
tenho outras preocupações então eu me
preocupo em avisar ele Por exemplo
quando eu vou ligar o liquidificador
para que ele não tem daqui
liquidificadores do mundo não vão parar
de funcionar mas que eu posso dar um
aviso para ele para ele ser prepararem e
tá mais confortável com aquilo então
mesmo assim da mesma mãe Amanda meus
três filhos Igualmente e tendo e a tia
não tô falando de regras que não pode
mais o outro que não pode desrespeitar
outro não eu tô falando de olhar
individualidade de cada um porque se eu
trago os meus três filhos iguais não vou
tá dando alguma coisa tão
o que não é o que ele precisa naquele
momento e eu vou estar ao mesmo tempo
esperando respostas ficam ser diferente
de cada filho o qual ele é mais tímido e
não vai uma pessoa que vai fazer uma
demonstração pública de afeto nunca mas
eu tenho que entender que ele é assim e
que ele vai demonstrar o amor dele de
outras formas para mim da mesma maneira
que fala não fala mas eu consigo sentir
o amor dela e outras coisas no gesto da
maneira vidraça da maneira que ela gosta
de ter o pé então se eu não enxergar
isso ficaram tomar esse trem se
comunicar de de necessitar da minha
atenção eu não vou conseguir dar o que
eles precisam para que eles cresçam bem
para que eles consigam ter com eles
precisam perceber que você dinheiro para
ser feliz porque a gente quer Quantas
contas e eu acho que quando a gente
transporta isso para medicina ou
qualquer na verdade porque
relacionamento entre médico e paciente
mãe e filho
em relações que a gente estabelece na
vida a gente precisa também precisa
olhar a gente não pode tratar todo mundo
igual existe existiu por um tempo e
agora eu acho que tá muito ficando essa
ideia de todos somos iguais Nós não
somos todos iguais ao contrário nós
somos todos diferentes e o que a gente
quer que as pessoas entendam que a gente
seja diferente e que agora isso que
entenda você na verdade às vezes não
precisam entender a gente não vai
conseguir entender o que eu passo mas
hoje você ouvir e não desconsiderar não
desvalidar pelo sim já é um passo enorme
o que a gente quer e eu alô precisamos
eu lembro de várias situações onde eu me
sentia linda esse tentações que não eu
lembro que a Anna quando ela nasceu hoje
ele machucada com síndrome de Down e
depois quando ela tinha cerca de cinco
meses eu passei no dentista da minha
cidade e era
a estudar pública e graças a Deus foi
uma experiência maravilhosa porque ela
não se colocou ali como numa posição
superior a mim aonde ela ia esfregar
tudo que ela perdeu de ciência e que ela
saberia mais que eu a preocupação dela
que eu entendesse exatamente o que se
passava como acontecer a síndrome de
Down eu lembro muito bem dela fazer
desenhos desenhar cromossomos explicado
a maneira mais simples que ela
entendesse que aquela linguagem chegou
até mim que eu entendi perfeitamente o
que acontecia e que ela também né
pudesse passar para mim tudo que eu
precisava me atentar e ela também nunca
colocou limites nunca falou que aquele
diagnóstico por exemplo seria
determinação de algum destino de coisas
que a minha filha Nunca faria isso faz
muita diferença
É nesse momento e a linha ela foi Além
daqui eu lembro que a gente quando chega
né não consigo novo descobre um
diagnóstico que não sabe muito bem e
pronto Navegar para onde ir e Alice de
potência uma ciência como a parte de
como eu como cidadão e atrás dos
direitos da minha filha ela foi a pessoa
que me falou olha você pode conseguir um
transporte público pela sua filha aqui o
formulário você tem direito ela tem o
direito ao benefício e você vai lá e
você pode ver se encaixa Então ela me
abriu para um mundo que eu não conhecia
ela sabia que eu não conhecia nada
daquilo que era necessário saber e ao
mesmo tempo eu lembro que eu fiquei
muito triste porque era uma profissional
que era muito mal vista pelo sistema de
saúde ela era por vezes colocada em
licença postada por que ela era uma
profissional que segundo o sistema de
saúde Aline tinha muitos dias eles não
gostar
o time tinha muitas vezes de exame e ela
só queria fazer o que cada paciente
precisava e saindo de lá ela me falou me
explicou tudo e eu sair de lá com todas
as informações e ainda uma suspeita de
que minha filha teria eu mando doença
Rara genética também equine muito mais
grave do que uma criança com síndrome de
Down e ela me aconselhou a procurar
outras mexe eu lembro de passar na
dermatologista que me falou que eu não
precisava me preocupar com aquilo
eu passei no pediatra da minha filha que
era o pediatra sensação do momento na
minha cidade todo mundo que ele aquele
pediatra Inclusive eu queria que ele
cuidado quando o meu que se deve segundo
nasceu mas ele não aceitava novos
parceiros então quando ele era o
plantonista no parto de emergência da
minha tia e quase Achei um sinal Divino
de que ele era para ser o que diabo e a
Lembra de levar sua preocupação para ele
e falar olha ela tem essas manchinhas
Pode ser que ela tem uma doença chamada
neurofibromatose tipo 1 e ele falou para
mim para eu parar eu tava procurando
pelo em ovo
Oi e aí nesse momento assim não sei aqui
talvez o que ele médico era ótimo mas
que ele não era um médico para minha
filha porque eles consideram o que eu
falava ele tratava minha filha com todas
as outras crianças e e não é isso a
gente precisa a gente precisa que o
profissional entenda que cada ocasião e
cada criança é uma criança e a minha
filha tem necessidades que precisam ser
olhados diferente de uma criança tipo e
não conhece pelo estava lá naquele ou
continua aqui então depois de dois meses
minha filha foi diagnosticado com ele os
problemas tipo onde eletricista
especialista em Síndrome de Down
o que me passou todos os protocolos de
monitoramento de tratamento caso algo
fosse acontecer
e e e aí nesse momento eu comecei a
experimentar esses dois lados de deter
pessoas que te fale não que escutam e
pessoas que nem tão e eu acho que a
intenção não lhe Neymar as coisas que
não estão preparados talvez na escola
Luciene não sei como é mas eu acho que
além de saber eu não acho que todo mundo
precisa saber sobre todas as doenças
ninguém vai saber de tudo mas eu acho
que o ouvir o de considerar a pessoa no
próprio tratamento de ouvir as
informações que ela vai estrada que vai
ser rir se você quer tratar uma pessoa e
você não entende que tá acontecendo na
casa dela você vai passar coisas que
muitas vezes ela não vai conseguir fazer
porque ela não tem o caso porque ela não
tem esporte porque eu não tenho dinheiro
para gastar com 20 horas de terapia na
semana Então como que você vai
simplesmente passar a mesma coisa para
todos os pacientes sem considerar a
realidade daquela pessoa
Oi e Eu graças a Deus te dê muitas
experiências boas também a longo dessa
caminhada de vários diagnósticos de
clínicas e eu sei a diferença que que
faz você é tão uma resposta no tipo de
interação quanto o outro quando a gente
vai atrás um sistema de saúde Qualquer
que seja seja uma terapia dentista você
já não conta mais geralmente você tá
apresentado você tá com medo de receber
algum diagnóstico ou você tá indo com
dor e a última coisa que você quer ser
julgado não sei estudada tem muita gente
hoje quando a gente fala de mãe que o
único momento que ela tem que ter que
realmente talvez achar que vai ser
escutada no consultório
e não é porque não na sociedade na
família muitas vezes a gente é julgada
pessoa Entendi então tá bom vou falar
com alguém entende daquilo então eu vou
poder descer para fazer o último meio
que você tem para ser escutada e você
não é desconsiderado Agorinha em janeiro
eu notei que a Hannah tinha dois duas
bolinhas dentro da boca e eu com todo o
conhecimento que eu tenho sobre a
neurofibromatose e sabendo que a doença
se começa a manifestar na época que a
criança está passando pela puberdade é o
que eu falei bom pode ser alguma coisa
relacionada e eu lembro de passar a
neurologista neurologista não conseguiu
ver porque ainda não deixa uma criança
nem complexa mede disse avaliar ali na
hora sem anestesia então eu não
conseguiu ver mas ela falou
provavelmente amar o playboy eu já tive
assim ó
Já faz mais de um mês que a minha filha
tá com isso passa um Pediatra o pediatra
da minha filha e não é a pediatra dela
oficial é um Pediatra que eu tive por
conta de mudança de convênio eu tive que
ir nesse novo pediatra que é muito
gentil mas ele entende de ver a criança
nele pesar vice fui Piton E aí quando eu
falei para ele da minha preocupação ele
falou que pode ser um deles me dá uma
pomadinha para passar e falou para
passar no gasto Inter o lojista E aí eu
fui na gasta expliquei falei para ela e
depois de um tempo ela voltou e falou
para mim que ela achava que eu tinha
razão
quem não sabe que é melhorou sobrou uma
que estava se formando depois pode
crescer isso isso não cor e ela falou
acho que você tem razão eu acho que tem
a ver quando era sobre mitose pela faz
tempo e ele nesse momento eu chorar
assim de alívio até estranho de falar e
looks que já tivesse uma manifestação da
doença mas eu chorei por eu ter sido
vida sabe aqui na livro de que fala
assim eu não sou
e eu eu sei porque me preocupar eu não
tô procurando pelo em ovo de novo só que
não tá sempre as coisas para poder me
adiantar minhas coisas e poder dar o
melhor para minha filha Então nesse
momento meu emocionei por ser ouvida
Então essa dificuldade pessoas não tenha
a noção do que é isso e as pessoas que
vivem nessa situação muitas mães amigas
já usa essas coisas assim de vocês não
gerada você tá vendo carinhoso das
famílias das pessoas que estão próximas
que não vida aquela realidade no dia a
dia então assim Ouçam Vocês precisam
ouvir não quer dizer que toda vez eu vou
tá certo toda vez eu vou aceitar mas que
dizem que eu preciso ter ouvido que eu
passo para minha filha seu que eu
convivo com ela eu sei as alterações
dela de humor as alterações físicas
então a a nossa opinião precisa ao menos
a esperada e se a pessoa não sabe fala
Olha eu não sei mas eu acho que tem
alguém que pode te ajudar vamos juntos
resolver isso já tem vários médicos aqui
que tava ali junto comigo trouxe um
lencinho falou chora mesmo e já teve
terapeuta de alimentação que me abraçou
e falou a senhora não tá fazendo nada de
errado é só filha não importa o seu sua
filha não tá comendo na colher o
objetivo da alimentação e não se o coco
e a gente se vê que ela tá no Trina uma
criança que recebe alimentação pela GTT
pela sonda ou pela boca ela não é mais
ou menos que nem um outra então você tá
fazendo seu papel e as pessoas não têm
noção como coisa simples e sentir um
parte só de você porque eu tava fazendo
coisa errada eu sei que eu não fiz o que
não devia tempo e coisas assim
e nessa situação estava aqui em Mãe você
tá fazendo sua parte não se preocupe com
isso tem falado que tinha um peso que
faz gostoso e com foco do que precisa
mas o Ju eu eu tenho foco no que estas
que precisa resolver hoje amanhã eu vou
acordar vou resolver amanhã mas aos
poucos e contando pessoas que conseguem
enxergar que consegue enxergar todos os
cenários de não ter só anda de tem
outras duas crianças que estão bem Vocês
vão de atenção especial de todos
contexto e vê como isso pode me ajudar
seja com uma palavra seja por uma
formação seja com um arquivo desse por
exemplo a esse arquivinho chama tão
arquivo da vida
e foi uma médica de uma clínica complexa
que deu a mais que 20 você coloca na
geladeira e tem toda uma lista de
Diagnósticos dano dos médicos dos
Remédios de tudo que ela precisa das
necessidades dela que não lembra gente
se eu não tiver aqui por exemplo o algo
aconteça ou esteja muito nervosa e não
conseguiu falar com a simplesmente pegar
a isso aqui que a pessoa e ela vai
entender que a Ana não pode fazer a
criança que ela tem esse isso aquilo que
ela não pode tomar medicação junto com
outra então são pequenas coisas e as
mais ficar muito a nossa vida como uma
paciente com muita eu acho que a gente
tem que pesar um pouquinho a ciência
assim isso é muito necessário mas você
não toque de humanidade de dar conexão
com o outro que tá ali na sua frente
e não vai produzir os melhores
resultados talvez vai prolongar um
tratamento que poderia ter sido muito
mais reduzido efetivo se você conseguir
seu ver conseguir aquela pessoa tá
sentindo tá passando Qual é a coisa que
acontece ao redor da vida dela
bom então o a minha mensagem aqui Aqui
as pessoas possam ser consideradas no
seu próprio tratamento vitaminas podem
ser ouvidas que os sentimentos possam
ser validados que a gente possa ser
levado em consideração uma situação que
a gente passa os nossos sentimentos e
que a gente não seja colocado numa
caixinha aqui com todo mundo que a gente
fez aqui todo mundo é diferente por isso
mesmo a gente tem necessidades
diferentes de conexão de atendimento da
mesma forma que eu como mãe dos meus
três filhos eu preciso tratar cada um de
maneira diferente entendeu que motiva o
que faz feliz e com a necessidade do
outro o profissional ao também na saúde
ele precisa entender que cada pessoa é
diferente e que nem todo mundo vai
precisar da mesma resposta nem todo
mundo vai precisar da mesma coisa
naquele momento
é obrigado a